but in the last week cases have dropped
by
30 percent almost a third this is
clearly good news
it shows that the national restrictions
have been successful
and what this means in practice is that
through everyone's
actions in respecting the national
lockdown
and through everything that people have
sacrificed
we've reduced pressures on the nhs we've
brought down the number of coronavirus
cases
we've got this virus back under control
and i want to thank you for that and for
the part that you've played
the effect of the action that we take of
course brings with it huge
challenges too especially for the
hospitality sector
and as the analysis of health economic
and social effects of covert 19 and the
approach to tiering
shows which we've published today it
clearly
demonstrates this action is necessary
to avoid a much worse outcome and we
must be vigilant
there are still 14 778
positive cases reported every day and
there are still
those fifteen thousand seven hundred and
twelve people in hospital with covid
and sadly there are still 460 reported
deaths
on average each day this is far too many
but there is light at the end of the
tunnel we know that together we can beat
this
and we've got to stick at it
putting this in technical terms the r
rate is back below one
but only just when r is below one
the number of infections falls over time
because on average
each infected person infects fewer than
one
other and for that to happen on average
it's important that lots of infected
people infect no one else at all
this is the central challenge of this
pandemic
and it's made much much more difficult
because about one in three people with
coronavirus
have no symptoms at all but nevertheless
they pass the infection on
to others and that is why even as we
ease these national restrictions
we've got to keep some restrictions in
place
and hence the tiering system so while we
can let up a little
we can't afford to let up a lot
the success of our collective efforts
means that from wednesday
everyone in england even those in tier
three
can have some greater freedoms but we
don't have much headroom
we can't risk letting cases rise again
especially into christmas and with the
flu season around the corner
the prime minister has published the
government's covid winter plan
which sets out the international
restrictions and the steps that we'll
take
to help to bring life back to normal by
spring
but even as we take those steps forward
we must keep our resolve
we've worked so hard and collectively
sacrificed
so much but we can get through this
and i know that hope is on the horizon